[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool
threads it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
that's called the rev sip rev yeah look
you start slowly start like
you start you just a little bit like
oh man and then you get four uh 14
sequels
i saw one and we'll talk china we'll
talk about some films
today i saw one precisely one fast and
furious yeah uh and it was because it
was a second film of a double feature to
drive in
and i still wanted my money back i mean
that's
obvious and then and then there was one
right before it was like pre ronda
rousey and they said no this one's more
of like a thriller it's very similar to
the italian job remember i rented that
with mom and by the way papa crowder's
here dave leno gets back tomorrow
the austin minis and we started watching
it and we said this isn't this isn't
like italian job at all
this isn't like the score it just sucks
it's vin diesel
flunking but grades um
uh so we have a lot to get to today
billy eilish i hope i promised that
correctly elliott page not billy elliot
though really at this point they all
could compete in the same sports
division
and uh we have to talk about the cia
teachers indoctrinating your youth we
have a life
it's a lot to get to gerald is here hey
how are you sir
horrible oh how are you recording black
hair doing good
i don't know what that is but uh i think
it's his attempt
thank god he's not my security and papa
crotter thanks for being here got
railroaded into the sea yeah kind of
later on
dave's not he's under the seat yes he
had a growth removed himself
diddy it is not benign but it's not
cancer it's just a part of dave
he had the surgery the bottom surgery
you're saying yeah oh okay yeah
they removed it they said oh my gosh
this looks like it belongs to you
so um get well soon before we move on to
uh the teachers indoctrinating your
youth and of course the trans issues of
the day
and of course billy eilish and why she's
a satanist i know now what do you mean
i'll explain it later first the cia um
is now they've changed you know we used
to think cia fbi
yeah right u.s marshals we used to think
they're there to say they're they're not
important they're there to be the best
of the best of the best trained to eat
things would make a village
richard crenna it's a classic well it's
a far cry from richard crenna
you gotta work out because now this is
the cia's new recruitment video
and uh let's see what they're they're
putting their best their best
multicultural leg
forward i'm a woman of color
i am a mom i am a cisgender millennial
who's been diagnosed with generalized
anxiety disorder i am intersectional
but my existence is not a box checking
exercise
declaration a woman whose inflection
does not rise at the end of her
sentences
suggesting that a question has been
asked i used to struggle with imposter
syndrome
but at 36 i refuse to internalize
misguided patriarchal ideas of what a
woman can or should
be i am tired of feeling like i'm
supposed to apologize
for the space i occupy rather than
intoxicated
my brilliance i am proud of me
oh no well i'm glad that makes one of us
and by the way here's the thing too this
is first off it's just
china's laughing at us they just banned
feminism in china in the chinese
military wow
dang it and they don't even have a if
you try and explain you try and ask them
or call them i'm like well why
why would you ban feminism oh because
women weak
why would you not we want military to be
physically strong yeah yeah sorry it's
like
maybe confused for western world we want
military and intelligence to be strong
right yeah women not very strong
terrible it's just i'm tired of the
patriarchal ideas you know what first
off
you you want the patriarchy on that line
you need the patriarchy on that line
look people think about the patriarch
and they think oh patriarchy means
sexual harassment it means abusing your
wife no no first off patriarchy
actually made it a crime where men were
actual you've heard whipping posts we
were tied to a post and whipped in the
town square if we abused our wives
because
men didn't like men who abused wives men
who
raped kids and men who beat women don't
fare that well in prison did you know
that
i do not but the patriarchy the idea of
the page cia
fbi special forces is hey we are to
protect the women and children among us
so that they can
nurture raise our children take care of
them and then of course propagate the
species
so we send the men out why because the
patriarchy said that the men
not the women and children are
expendable
but i'm glad you feel good about it but
they were right but i mean the big drop
the big takeaway here is that she
doesn't have her inflection doesn't go
up at the end of the sentence yeah
it just stays monotone thank goodness
which by the way is a negative female
stereotype unless it's a male to female
trans in which case it is brave and
beautiful have you noticed that
that all these negative females i am not
a blonde with big boobs
or an airhead i don't wear makeup i
don't wear heels and then caitlyn jenner
says
you're wrang and like the party don't
stop
till i'm walking look tits and a fan of
shares that's
all the splendor that is woman oh my god
now if we made those comments about up
talk like she did you know talking
finishing sentences like that but even
even male millennials
are doing that now or everything's a
question if we had said that we're the
patriarchy here yes
well we are the patriarchy and i'm proud
of it you can't take them seriously
it's it's one of those things look i
talked with my wife there was something
recently we were watching a show
pick a show any show and of course the
guy shows up and we're an idiot
um and we're completely inept and we'll
talk about billy eilish saying that men
are weak and i have to be everyone's mom
despite the fact that her older brother
is the one who risked and invested and
developed a studio and tosser and is a
vocalist
how do you make all of her music now
i've always if we spent half as much
time focusing
on raising good men and what makes a
good man as we do
denigrating all men think about this you
have women's day you have women's month
you have women's visibility day you have
the women's march
you get father's day with men that's
about it that's about it and you grow a
mustache in november
i just for the same reason i've wanted
i've wanted men
to respect women i've talked about
abstinence in the past i've talked about
respecting women i've talked about being
a good leader being a good husband we
talk about that
all the time i'm also advocating for
women out there
look try and have a little bit of
empathy for men
every time they tune into something
they're pieces of [ __ ] imagine if i just
said you know what by and large women
are weak
i'm not doing an impression of a chinese
military leader as i just did that cover
but
that was weak women are awful you know
what women aren't as smart as men that's
that's what you see with the billy irish
interview that's what you see here with
the cia it's all these negative
stereotypes of men
and just as right now you're seeing a
statistic of more people because of
black lives matter riots more people
because of critical race theory
feeling like they're more racist you're
going to see more people
feel like they're sexist yeah you can
only browbeat men so long because they
have a penis or women with a penis we
get it
before they start saying hey you know
what i think we've actually done some
pretty good stuff
yeah exactly i mean and if you're a
woman watching this show right now we're
not crapping on women what we're doing
is
you need strong confident men and right
now everybody is making the case that
men are bad just like you said and women
are this
protected class and that's fine we want
to protect them that's what we do right
but don't act like every single man out
there is horrible and can't hold a job
and doesn't understand
life and then expect them to be nice and
kind and loving when it comes time to
get married you can't talk about how
awful men are and how you don't need a
man how you don't want a man and then be
35 realize your window is closing and
wondering where all the good men are
going to and they don't want to marry
you
i don't need a man to be happy uh you
will guess what because
everyone really most people need a
spouse to be happy yes
it's better than living life alone just
like you saw in weddings no fonzie
doesn't work because no one wants to see
a 60 year old henry
winkler hit on chicks well we do have to
be careful though we can't be too
victomy
because then that's weak right yeah well
of course it's not lost honestly no i'm
just saying this ultimately hurts women
this ultimately
but you know what hey sure men are
leaving the the marriage pool in record
numbers right they don't want to father
children
they're they don't want to pay child
support at this point women are finding
themselves
lonely single higher rates of depression
unhappy they realize in their 40s that
careers aren't all that fulfilling but
good
you know what good thing is you can join
the cia without uh apparently no pt
requirements there so
let's move on to teacher appreciation
week
this is going right now teacher
appreciation week i don't participate
um it's trending
no sorry the real heroes appreciate yeah
oh
yes correct this the real heroes
appreciation week
you know what i'm in a mood did let me
explain to you why i'm in the mood i
tried to go to the gym this morning and
there were two
guys curling in the squat rack anyone
deal with this comment they better
20 minutes they had five pounds on it
maybe 10. so 65 pounds 20 minutes my
workout was gone
and i realized you know i was trying to
be polite and so i i
should have murdered all of them i would
have the choice
there are a lot of times that i would
turn you in for murder that you think
it's justifiable and i don't but in this
case
i'm not going to absolutely not at all
don't curl in a squat rack no
kind of people who that they become top
ranked cia officials well and it's bad
enough but it
at least put some weight on the bar if
you're going to be in there no don't
point
leave leave don't use a bar leave
decrease the surplus population
so teacher appreciation week is trending
number one right now on twitter
um in recognition here's a recent clip
of the beautiful brave heroes the real
heroes professors from roosevelt
university
talking about exactly what it is that
they're teaching your kids when they
have them completely unfettered and you
have no access or the ability to
uh mold young minds this is what they do
i'm so glad you're there too you fit in
so well with their
you know the university's philosophy and
mission right
and it's all social justice all day
every day i get to talk about
all the things i love yeah i always flip
out the kids that take my master's class
on fiscal policy and public budgets when
the first
three or four classes are devoted to
philosophy of
social justice and how you organize
society we don't talk about one
you know budgetary item they're like oh
man
professor martiri this is a really weird
way to teach a budget
yeah yeah it's a really weird way to
teach a budget by not
teaching a budget yeah just take other
people's money
that's your budget yeah it's like this
is the this is a perfect example of
where it only works in academia and this
is why i don't think and you know what
it bothers me you see a lot of
conservatives say
oh academia it's an indoctrination
factor but their kids all have to pull
the strings to get them into harvard to
get them into brown
yeah listen my my twins i am going to be
openly advocating against them going to
an expensive university in-state school
community college trade school and uh i
want to teach them fiscal responsibility
and the skill set as to how you most
effectively learn
it's not in college they just said
people come to us
our job is to teach them a budget and
instead i teach them a bunch of other
stuff
only in academia trade schools like okay
i'm going to become a plumber right
but instead i want to talk about the
lack of plumbers of color well
you know what listen i came mario at one
point they were an oppressed people
it's olive nowhere else you know why you
know why because you don't run a
business
because in academia there are no
consequences you can just you basically
have
a forced audience anyone here by the way
when i went to college
anyone experience this when you go to
college you have to buy two 300
textbooks that your professor wrote and
nobody else would ever read
yeah well they just gave them to us in
the football program sorry oh well good
for you
and then they showed up and they were
they changed one thing and you had to
buy the abridged version oh
yeah yeah buy the new one but don't
worry it was an annuity for these guys
yeah you can sell it back for ten
dollars
yeah so exactly there's that it's just
an absolute
racket it's always social justice oh i
thought you were teaching economics well
i don't know anything about it that's
why i'm a professor
i think that's the best thing that we
could do is open up teaching to the free
market like you you have to be good
enough to justify your pay
and they would freak out that's why they
want to do away with standardized
testing
you mean have some kind of
accountability yeah you know you know
your team's supposed to teach a budget
economics at the end of the at the end
of the year we're gonna have
standardized testing to see if your kids
know how to balance a budget
your kids just wrote malcolm x 15 times
in the queue
and by the way that was a scantron they
actually
statistically less than random because
they didn't even pick the multiple
choice they wrote malcolm x
red fox and [ __ ] you in here i don't
know
and it wasn't even a number two pencil
it was creative though yes
they said those tests are racist though
they literally say they're racist or
they're socially
socioeconomic biases in those tests so
we can't use those tests
here's what i want i want and you guys
you know what comment the best thing you
can do is comment uh comment below it's
the best that helps the algorithm and i
want to know if you experienced that in
college for me i was going wait i have
to buy a 300
textbook what is really imp important is
the left wants you to think
especially when they do these polls and
they do them every election cycle and
they talk about uh you know the educated
elite you know if you listen to aaron
sorkin
they want education meaning higher
education university to be inextricably
tied
with being knowledgeable with being
intelligent with being
you know what i would even say educated
the current educational system
that one you just saw there does not
educate young americans
and so i think for people who say well
i'm not left or right i see everything
on an individual basis
that's great i don't believe and that's
necessarily when you're looking through
the prism of politics i think you need
some kind of an ideology
at least so you have a framework but
when it comes to judging people
as to whether they are educated
intelligent or not how about we do this
how about we take everyone on an
individual basis and don't judge them
based on a piece of paper which is
really just congratulations your parents
check cash
uh or student loan which will be paid
off you're welcome by the way we've paid
for it with tax dollars from our
business
it's become really expensive karate yes
basically where where's your belt too
accurate gerald
uh so here's another one before we get
to before we get to uh billy eilish and
uh what's the other one billy eilish and
elliott elliott
elliott oh my god elliott i saw we were
watching this this morning you know we
always watch cnn in the morning i hate
it yeah
i know we watch it i read mostly liberal
sources
that's why i think this this web this
website this show is a little bit
different although sources are available
at lighter with credit.com
um link in the description and i was
watching cnn and they pulled this this
morning you know
we've talked about how they pull the
selective edit of the uh the very fine
people on both sides and they never show
donald trump saying i'm not talking
about white supremacists and neo-nazis
who should be condemned totally almost
as much as brian stelter that's about
what he said
they always cut that out well sometimes
it's right they they cut it out
and they don't really address it then
it's sort of a lie by omission
in this case they actually they
proactively
respond to something and selectively
edit the speech
on january 6th to make it seem like
donald trump didn't call
people to peacefully protest i i
couldn't believe
it well i can't believe it here's a clip
from this morning i think it was around
uh it was around 8 10 8 10 a.m again we
have all this uh on lotto crowder.com
it was a relatively slim 87 vote margin
on a resolution that said romney
shouldn't have voted to impeach trump
claiming that donald trump's 2019 call
to the ukrainian president where he
threatened to hold up foreign aid in
exchange for an investigation into his
political opponent
was perfectly okay and that trump far
from inciting the january 6 riots urged
his followers to peacefully
and patriotically make your voices heard
okay we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell
you're not going to have a country
anymore
talk about dishonest she goes okay do
you really think he said that
i'm gonna show a clip where he doesn't
say it again we've been through this ad
nauseam of course
the president did say make your voices
patriotically peacefully heard
this is what they didn't show you i know
that everyone here will soon be marching
over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
that wasn't an accident that was a
proactive lie and i will say this people
say well you know what there's a lot of
problem big tech
a lot of problems with people losing
trust in our institutions and we need
real journalism
if that's real journalism we don't need
it just like if those are real teachers
we don't need it if that's the real cia
we don't need it okay you can tell us
that we do but we don't
every now and then i'll get caught with
something where i'll go oh you know what
that does okay
and i need to look at it and i realize
it's a lie cnn
they lie about everything there should
be
zero trust none whatsoever in cnn and
you know what cnn msnbc fox news
you should always always verify that's
why we make our sources available you
shouldn't trust me
you shouldn't trust anybody but
certainly not cnn
i cannot believe that they are
considered a legit revoke their press
pass can i do that
yeah come on right now or at least
classify them as an opinion show right
and not actual news
they were doing this in a broader story
you and i actually got pissed off at
this independent of each other
i was watching it and tweeted out about
it i was like i can't believe what they
just did
they were saying that people that were
booing romney and people that made kind
of speeches against romney
are the same people that said this and
that's when she ran into that i'm like
you guys think we've liked romney all
these years have you not been paying
attention
then you're gonna call a guy a liar
saying that donald trump you're not even
just saying trump right you're saying
this guy's a liar and can't be trusted
about romney because he said this about
trump and trump of course didn't say
peace trump of course did not say that
what yeah you were watching it it's like
three levels of lying and you were upset
now it was like in home alone too where
i'm saying good night mom in front of
rockefeller plaza and you were looking
out your window and yeah yes
exactly we had a kindred moment
stelter's an
[ __ ] but you know she went in live
she would call herself an anchor yeah
okay
now walter cronkite wouldn't have gone
okay yeah by the way
what what happened to uh they were
biased are we allowed to denigrate up
talk in that scenario
okay okay uh okay all right
by the way shed some weight
and they will not let me just one final
point they will not let
this go the big lie we're gonna hear
about the big lie
forever and that was used in germany
about the jews
they're pulling that into this and
saying that is comparable eight hundred
people out of two hundred
thousand people is comparable to that
that the election was stolen
right that's the big lie we're going to
hear that over and over and over and
over and that trump's a part of the
party
that nobody can get around right still
in control he's pulling the string
somewhere behind the scenes you hate
trump right
yeah that's exactly what we're going to
hear for them you know what i don't want
to hear over and over someone's phone
keeps vibrating is that pops crowder no
someone shut off your damn phone this
isn't cnn we run a professional outfit
it's not me no we lie sometimes yeah we
do everything we do
no we have sources not like yes all
right he's speaking speaking of uh
sources speaking of references here
this is something that interests me
trevor not trevor no he never interests
me he never interests anybody
but um he's a thing still still no
apparently dang it uh apparently
i want to get that little kid on the
show uh so last week
trevor noah this is just something and
actually a good friend of mine uh who
used to be on youtube quite a bit i
don't know if i can use them as a
reference so i'll be careful yeah but uh
uh he denounced the cdc's new guidelines
trevor noah
um talking about this is just watch this
clip
and see if you can sort of spot the
inconsistency here's trevor noah talking
about cdc guidelines
i know science is difficult and this is
a novel virus and all of that
but who's running messaging at the cdc
huh
first they said mosques make us less
safe oh don't wear a mask then they
certainly
must make us more safe and now according
to this new chart
mosques can make you not safe again and
the most
funny thing about this chart is that
they've spent months they spent five
months
telling us to get vaccinated oh get
vaccinated and this will all be over get
vaccinated and i was like great i'll get
all the four vaccines if it means i'll
get my life back
but now now they're putting out a chart
and it says even if you get vaccinated
you can only do two more things without
a monster french blood diamond
guys what the hell the [ __ ] you're
saying to people is incoherent
you're telling us these new vaccines are
95 effective and will stop coronavirus
but we still can't do anything without a
mask on anyway which is it
is this one of the most effective
vaccines in the history of the world or
does it not work
it's not clear messaging especially if
you're desperately
trying to convince people to get the
vaccine accidentally
based apartheid oh my this guy look he
just went up in my uh
my book he didn't mean to there's a book
i love how they put
viral rant at the bottom like isn't that
something that actually happens yeah the
rant like you don't just declare it a
violence
it's predetermined if you know that
there's going to be millions of dollars
invested into running that as a payroll
ad
uh look first off i don't disagree with
him at all but the problem is of course
he was insulting anybody who said this
uh before his rant on that day which i
believe was friday maybe it was thursday
keep in mind too ron desantis not just a
not just a a diversity hire at comedy
central but an actual sitting governor
oh yeah um had medical professionals
from i want to make sure i get this
right harvard stanford oxford
was banned for doing exactly what trevor
noah
is doing right here going against the
cdc wow he's going against the cdc with
what he's saying
keep in mind our coveted anniversary the
entire special right we did
15 days to flatten the curve one year we
went through all of the cdc stances
all of the world's health organization
stances all of the data on masks
all of the data on the vaccines and
operation warp speed
and we were removed that episode was
removed you can still watch it
uh at mug club live earthquaker.com club
along with like 30 banned episodes
yeah i wonder if they're gonna remove
this episode because we played trevor
noah's episode i have
no idea and not only that but by the way
what they removed us for was where we
were talking about mortality rates
saying that
covid is significantly more lethal for
old people and i won't say exactly that
it's significantly less lethal for some
specific demographic of people compared
to the flu
but i will say we use the actual cdc
mortality rates
so that's kind of relevant we were still
removed from it we got a statement from
youtube that we were removed from
basically basically so if it's is it
really about denying science or are
these policies dictated by
uh whatever your political opinion of
the day is and again even our intern by
the way
uh reported the video uh lily and i
believe uh choi junior reported
this video for going against youtube's
uh guidelines not even as not even a
strike not even a warning not even a
fact check
and i hate to do this because i think
that what he said was right but
you've look we've got to be fair here so
i would advocate everyone out there go
watch this
viral rant uh from trevor noah and flag
it flag it as a violation of community
guidelines just because i want to see if
it's
consistently applied if it is applied
across the board
equally you do not live in a free
society and you don't it's not a free
platform
if laws or rules exist it's whether they
are applied
equally so for example if hillary
clinton
commits some kind of shady campaign
finance yeah nothing happens but trevor
noah's put on house arrest where he has
to breathe into his bracelet every 20 24
hours
that means that you don't live in a free
society if the irs targets political
opponents but they don't they treat
people who are
of their own political ilk more more
kindly
you don't live in a free society so
everyone you can go if you don't want to
search it on youtube just go to
livecredit.com
and click the link flag it as a
violation of community guidelines we'll
circle back and see what happens i don't
want to be removed i would hope that
this would result in youtube saying
hey you know what we need to do away
with these bs guidelines
or they're just going to say well look
viacom comedy central they pay us a lot
of money and so we'll let it slide
absolutely i mean maybe they should come
back and say look when a sitting
governor is talking to medical
professionals
the american public or at least the
public in the state that he's in has a
right to hear what he has to say
let's hear the conversation you're
shutting down all people who have a
viable opinion by the way this isn't
somebody who got it online we've talked
about this these are doctors from some
of the best
institutions on the planet having a
conversation mispronounced
science deniers that's true yeah oxford
harvard stanford
certainly it's not trevor noah with a
webcam yeah south of the mason dixon i
guess those degrees don't apply which we
have an entire segment coming up on why
trevor knows objectively not funny i
just this is the thing everyone always
says this when they disagree with
someone oh he's not [ __ ] people say that
with me and maybe
maybe you think i'm not that's totally
fine i don't care yeah i think that john
stewart was funny i think steven bear
was funny when he was i think
uh bill mark can sometimes kind of be
funny if a little [ __ ] kathleen
madigan's probably my favorite female
comedian of all time well known far left
the thing is trevor noah is objectively
unfunny and
talk about dated i can't think of anyone
less hip than someone doing
a youtube short video circa 2009 exactly
and quick cuts
and then he's yelling but he's not
really yelling because he's he's not
committed to it just like he's not
committed to his career
and comedy central apparently not all
that committed to the network's uh
success solvency uh all right speaking
of science well you watch you were a fan
of we watched jon stewart we watched him
do stand up at the just for last month
always funny and he used to come on fox
and destroy those guys yeah he was very
smart yep he made bill o'reilly look
like a fool
well rightfully so to be fair he wasn't
prepared he was too busy tuning the
radios of the interns
oh gee you're never going to get a
station tuning them like e.t in a corner
he likes to grab intern's nipples folks
i think halo riot is clear i think you
can oh
that's what oh okay just looking out for
the folks
this is the no spin zone
terrible that's awesome i used to get so
much flack when i would say this about
bill o'reilly while i was still on air
i'm glad that i don't anymore
everybody comes around eventually so
speaking of of science speaking of
of medical experts uh stephanie rule
this is and we're going to go into
elliott page but this is perfect a
perfect lead because stephanie rule
grilled
uh west virginia governor jim justice
over the transgender sports bill yeah
and um i will say this the problem is
that the the
governor here totally botched his
response but it doesn't change the fact
that mrs rule is satisfied with herself
uh in a way that she has
uh no right to be can you give me
one example of a transgender child
trying to get an unfair advantage just
one in your state you signed a bill
about it
no i i can't really tell you one if you
cannot name one single example for me
of a child doing this why would you make
this a priority i believe
that girls worked so hard facing
title nine and i do not have any idea
now
why we are trying to disadvantage them
in participating in the sport
that they put so much into i don't know
why we're doing it
this is not like it's a big priority to
me in fact i think we only have 12
no stephanie listen i think we only have
12
kids maybe in our state that are
the worst argument ever i mean for
crying out loud stephanie
i signed hundreds of bills hundreds look
how satisfied she is with herself and
her
lack of upper lip and bic pen and got
him
first off um yeah that's not don't don't
apologize
sometimes people answer and this is a
problem with cable news i've told you
this where they want to speak for as
long as possible
and they want to give the opposing point
of view as little time as possible
so it's not actually conducive toward
making an effective argument
what you just say is oh don't be silly
we just don't want men competing with
girls
and then she'd be click she would be
clicking her pen nervously like the
invincible guy in goldeneye she'd have
no idea what to do
so this is also something an argument
we've been through this uh used by trans
advocates
uh well it hasn't happened yet in uh in
west virginia it could not be less
relevant
but um it's actually the appeal to
novelty intellectual argument some
people we can bring it up in latin
argument and add
novotem nova tatum this fallacy is the
opposite of appeal to tradition and that
it is an attempt to claim that the
newness or modernity
modernity of something is evidence as to
its truth and superiority the novelty of
the idea or proposition does not entail
its truth or falsity so what you're
saying is well in west virginia this
hasn't happened yet
okay that doesn't matter it would be
like saying other places in europe well
you know you don't need to protect the
jews the holocaust hasn't happened here
yet
not comparing no right some boy who
decides to be a girl
beating up girls in sports or setting
the records to the holocaust i'm just
saying it's the same kind of an
intellectual fallacy and it's an
intellectual fallacy that has been made
to excuse away horrible atrocities right
it hasn't happened yet
so why do we need to do something about
it well okay west virginia it hasn't
happened in west virginia yet
doesn't mean that it hasn't happened
across the globe we went through
multiple examples last week fallon fox
male to female fighter lived as a male
for most of his life father children
broke women's orderable
you have australian women's handball
champ hannah mouzy that's a hilarious
picture
made for great comedy so i'm not too mad
about it women's cycling world champ
rachel mckinnon set world records
two records in a trial ncaa champion
cece teflor master squad world record
holder
mary gregory the list goes on and on and
these are just in places where they
don't have laws and so they show up to
compete in women's division
and people are incredibly confused it is
man well and you're right they over
complicate the argument it's not
necessarily just about somebody like
don't make it
somebody taking a spot on an athletic
team in college don't make it about a
scholarship make it about fairness like
it doesn't make any sense
to put somebody who is physically
superior their entire life and i'm sorry
i don't mean that to degrade women i'm
just saying on average
and put them in a sport with women and
say that's fair and that's
normal if they want to compete fine the
the you can
don't apologize for saying that men are
physically stronger than women that's
not an insult to women and you know what
we have to acknowledge the truth to
protect women listen women
in order for the patriarchy to protect
you
meaning we're a part of the voting bloc
that you are as well in order to create
these laws
we need to acknowledge that men have an
unfair biological advantage over women
so we shouldn't be competing in your
sports okay so the truth is we start
with the truth stop being offended
men are physically stronger men have
more lung capacity men have denser bones
men have better endurance men have
different abilities in increasing their
blood sugar there are so many biological
advantages
when you start with the truth men are
physically more gifted than women and so
in order to make sure that women have an
equal playing field in their sports no
man should compete with you
you should let's not be offended at the
statistical the scientific reality
and instead be offended at the lie by
people who do so in the name of equality
because
hey there's the science isn't in yet we
have no idea if 12 to 25 times the
testosterone uh gives men an advantage
yeah we do
we do yeah we do and by the way in in
west virginia
uh there haven't this hasn't happened
yet yeah but they're they're
this is something too that people need
to know there there um actually have
been some examples that could have maybe
this is why they need a law yeah the
point is these things are coming up so
according to ucla
1.04 percent of teens age 13 to 17
identify as transgender in west virginia
the highest
of any state the hell's going on in west
virginia that's from ucla i have no idea
that it's accurate
i've never been to west virginia i have
no plans to go to west virginia i know i
think
if i'm not mistaken tim poole has a
skate park there
[Music]
that's about all i know that's about all
i know and i know that they're you know
a lot of flipper grandkids but
the point is this obviously could happen
and it has happened in
other states if you're gonna use that
argument fine well then
why do you need to have a mask mandate
why do you need why do you need to have
a vaccine passport in some states what
why do you have any of these well hasn't
happened in your state yet
and by the way one of the things she did
was put up all of the areas where west
virginia was lagging behind
other states saying oh you're so bad on
these things why don't you focus on this
like people can't do two things at one
time
he was right in saying i signed hundreds
of bills he just said it in a really
stupid way if he made your point and
then said hey by the way
i can do a lot of things at the same
time i sign tons of bills every single
day we're getting things done in west
virginia right this is just
one of them he should have just said
look look we are looking into improving
our educational system on a state level
including charter schools student
vouchers also
no peckers in the women's restrooms no
peckers it's not that well
it's going to happen by the way that
didn't even cost me any money
i just had to say no dicks in the
restroom no decks on the ladies
no decks on a lady's sports floor that's
it
case clothes we made shirts and
everything
i got a giant foam head check it out
all right we're about to see this sorry
these coastal elites that the
journalists really try to
it's a subtle way they make the south
look too yeah
and uh they try to embarrass them yeah
what they do they bring the worst
possible people on to discuss these
ideas because they can't
fight the idea itself so i have to bring
on somebody who can't articulate it and
go
well they sound stupid when they make
this argument let's bring them no he's a
he's a high level guy and yeah
no no i know but that's not saying a
whole lot apparently what you're doing
do a great job of making the argument he
should have had somebody come in and say
look i'm going on tv
tell me what but you know what though it
also it's there's also value in that
because it shows that the west virginia
hillbillies
are smarter than the coastal reporters
it's the west virginia well they're
uneducated out there in west virginia
but for some
reason they believe that biology
determines sex
they follow science exactly at least i
hear the banjo from deliverance
yeah by the way hey you can follow me on
instagram uh lotto with crowder on
instagram that's where we have some
stuff that can't be passed
half the times i do ask model
uh inadvertently oh you just may not
it's just my build it's called genetics
and it's a live show monday through
thursday at 10 a.m eastern just tune in
because notifications don't necessarily
work
best thing you can do is just comment
comment comment
below uh we have a lot to talk about
we're gonna be talking about elliott
paige and billy eilish hey
hey ellie and my like button too hit the
oh yeah smash
look at that oh
there you go finish him yeah smash it
like
elliott peach smash them twitter oh
got rid of them we're going to show you
we're going to show them why oh you see
that
how dare you smash burger chest so uh
elliott page
formerly helen page ellen yeah by the
way i was nominated for an academy award
for best actor
i thought that's kind of lazy naming you
just you just picked your uh gave
an uh interview to oprah yeah
as one one does okay of course uh during
a pendant oops
oprah's gotta get her i got her finger
wet too they're a little bit we gotta
get a little bit of profit for the oprah
there right then benjamin
we all are just fighting for scraps
she's got the whole damn pie so
elliot paige gave an interview with
oprah um and without before we get into
without giving too much pretext uh the
the you know should talk about the
elliot uh new production
here you go
oh god
[Applause]
okay i'd tune into that i'd watch it we
should have seen this coming
yeah many better people on clips so
before we get into the specifics here
um this is of course ellen page's
transition to elliot and look i will say
this
i do have some compassion and empathy
because uh well you can watch these
clips here and
i'll tell you this doesn't seem like
someone even though they keep saying it
who's very happy
uh and who's in a great headspace so uh
let's start this off here i
you know periods in my career where it
was just
it felt impossible to read a script in a
day just obviously when i was a kid
teenager at least my experience
i i that wasn't a part of the strained
voice
you know my life yeah and yeah i mean i
just was probably driving my friends
crazy
like sending them profile photos of me
you know
with like posts um having a
you know top surgery she's in a great
distance she's in a great head space
giving an interview sounds like bobcat
goldweight i feel happy i couldn't even
read scripts and
it shop and turn it down and then i hate
the girl and
it's my testicles it's like look this is
not someone who seems like they are
their
best self also i probably aggravate my
friends by sending them
uh you know my new pics of my chest
meaning
that they're unrequested uh that sounds
a little bit like bring up mayo clinic
yeah narcissistic personality disorder
one of several types of personality
disorders
is a mental condition in which people
have an inflated sense of their
own importance note this also includes
tits
uh a deep need for excessive attention
and admiration troubled relationships
and a lack of empathy
for others but behind this mask of
extreme confidence lies a fragile
self-esteem that's vulnerable to the
slightest criticism for reference to
that
of course just look at elliot page's
instagram and twitter timeline
unbelievably emotionally volatile right
so we have someone who is sending
unrequested pictures of their chest by
the way which would be if not for a
trans person considered sexual
harassment i'm probably driving them
crazy
hey not probably you're driving them
crazy and you can stop
and do now so someone who's emotionally
fragile someone who has no empathy for
people on the right you can see what
this person has done and we're
accusing people of being nazis racist
also by the way dave
stop sending me pictures okay nobody
wants this oh
geez and this is something you have to
see it now
talk about the drama remember when we
went from same-sex marriage
and by the way i caught a lot of flack
because back then i remember on the show
with dave and i said no
i'm not for it yeah so i said same-sex
same-sex civil unions sure
fine the problem is when you declare
marriage a fundamental human right
you've now said that men and women are
under
interchangeable i don't believe that two
dads can give everything to a kid that
to uh that a mom and a dad can and i
don't believe that two moms can
give everything to a child that a mother
and a dad can oh
okay and then we look into the reason
that marriage exists that marriage is
recognized by the government i wish that
i wish that it were not i wish that the
government wasn't in the marriage
running business but it's because we
understand before federal government
before state government before municipal
government the central governing body is
the nuclear family so i caught flack for
that yeah
that being said back then the argument
was what we do in our bedroom is our own
business
i always look that's not where it's
going to end it's not about what you do
in your own bedroom
as you can see now the argument has
changed from what we do in our own
bedroom is our own business to elliot
page goes on to say
if you do not support my political point
of view you want to
erase us yes i believe you people
want to erase trans people they
don't believe we exist and they don't
want to exist
and the fact that right now
right now the main tactic is to attack
trans kids
it's just it's unfathomable to me yeah
they want to erase trans people there
goes
arnold's sequel payday and i don't know
what has happened with
vanessa williams yeah since it's getting
really tough but
we're not attacking trans kids there's
no attack that's not what's going on no
not attacking trans kids at all if
anyone if anything the people who
are saying hey look putting kids on
puberty blockers or allowing them to
actually undergo
physical reassignment surgery that's the
opposite of protecting them
yeah stepping in to say hey maybe they
maybe they should be able to decide
their own bedtime before they chop off
their penis maybe that's a good idea
that's protecting kids that's not
attacking kids
we're attacking the enablers you
[ __ ] we're attacking people who put
kids out there
in parades and in protest when they have
no idea what's going on
and you're using them for political gain
yeah i feel bad for people like her
i really him sorry i didn't do that on
purpose
no i swear to you i didn't i need do i
need to read you a bedtime story
[ __ ] flew over the moon again i i do i
feel bad because i feel like they're in
a place
where they're hurting and they don't
understand how to do it and they've got
this entire group of people out there
saying hey come to us
we will use you for our political no
longer functioning eggs and ham
not at all there's a lot of we can keep
going on yeah absolutely
abc's no i do i feel genuinely terrible
you know what she goes on to say well
she she said that i think we had that in
that clip where she said um
the top surgery is life son of a i'm not
trying
to do this let's just go with the name
ellie
okay you know what let's go with the
name but you know it's like i said
everyone
blaire white was here yeah i always said
she of course because you would never
even
think that like look elliot page is a
perfect example of why
you don't see the inverse of what we
were just talking about uh girls
dominating men's sports
can you imagine that guy in a rugby
scrum
entertaining not that it would matter
how he she looks but that that's just a
that's just a gal it's so effeminate so
fine and this is a perfect example we
talk about hormones you've been on
you've been on hormones your whole life
it's called being a guy elliot page
could take testosterone for the rest
of his life you know what ellie if you
play your cards right
maybe you might reach chaz bono level oh
wispy mustache so
uh let's contrast the science to elliot
saying that the top surgery is
life-saving and we're not empathetic
well let's see
does gender reassignment surgery how
does that affect the 41
attempted suicide rate with trenches
it's still 41. it actually went up to 42
in one study
yeah which statistically is
insignificant but it doesn't get any
better
which would suggest that it's that
gender dysphoria is not
merely a symptom of someone being in the
wrong body however you still see
an incredibly high suicide rate a higher
suicide rate than you see with
jews in the holocaust or american slaves
or people with manic depressive disorder
they don't have a 42 attempted suicide
rate
that's just insane i don't think it's
because of the target bathroom
okay and then of course uh elliott page
uh
again talking about hyperbolic right
again it used to be hey what we do in
our own bedroom
no one here has a problem with we're
going to get to caitlyn jenner in a
second oh boy no one has a problem with
whatever you want to do in your own time
and call yourself
the problem is with the fundamental
changing of society and that everybody
else has to take part
especially now at a point where it is
undeniable
that it will cause harm to others namely
the more vulnerable among us
young women in sports but remember you
will be
forced to care here's the hyperbole from
or
maybe elliott believes this on
transgender sports
and because there is such an attack on
trans healthcare right now
when already there's such lack of access
or trans people who don't even want to
go to the doctor
what you are hearing from certain
lawmakers
are actual complete and utter
they're other lies in terms of what
they're saying about
the healthcare and the reality of the
health care is that
it's supported by medical institutions
and it saves lives
and if you are going to do this johns
hopkins and if you are also not going to
allow trans kids to play sports
children will die and it really is that
simple
children will die thank you ghost of
christmas yet to come i see an
empty penis pump by the fire
and a soccer ball if elliott plays a
contact sport
people will yeah people yeah as well yes
uh one person will die yeah so
we're tr and this is something too let's
go back to stephanie rule right we just
had this argument in west virginia since
we're trusting the science right this is
what matters and the argument
is uh or was who in west virginia has
been harmed by
transgenders in male sports you can't
point to one example so why
sign a bill despite the fact that there
have been many examples of course across
the globe
and in other states right certainly more
examples there so that's the standard
they use
you can't find one example okay well
right here elliott page just made a
definitive statement wasn't fact checked
at all by oprah
how let's go now to the research to the
science to the data
how many deaths have there been due to
trans
children not being allowed to compete in
cross-gender intramural sports
riveting well [ __ ] wow that's uh awkward
can i point out that oprah was
considerably larger than elliot
yes yes yes well she always has been
okay yeah that's right that's very true
but it looked like uh looks like a jason
whitlock
oh my goodness you know what i wish in
some of those
that and oprah could do it in a pretty
good way she could compassionately push
back
she could compassionately ask a simple
question
how will they die yeah or or what what
do you mean by the health care
you said it four times and you strained
a few times to say it
don't you think maybe that it's
reasonable that kids can't necessarily
make those life-altering decisions at
such a young age
that's a legitimate argument healthcare
you're asking me about how kids can't
make me dance
i mean really that that's all you have
to do is ask a couple of probing
questions
and then i mean don't use that sorry
a couple of questions right you could do
that without being hateful you can do
that just to say hey here's the argument
that people would make isn't this a
reasonable question
isn't this something that we have to
address and you know how i know that
that's a fair
uh that's a fair question to ask and
it's also
a fair statement it's also a fair
position to hold
future governor of california caitlyn
jenner had this to say
about transgender uh athletics
so there's legislation in various states
to ban biological boys who are trans
from playing girl sports in school
what's your opinion on that
inbox and
this is a question of fairness
that's why i oppose biological boys who
are trans
competing in girl sports in school it
just
isn't fair now look
hey uh i think that caitlyn jenner is
saying that because caitlyn jenner knows
that bruce would have simply eviscerated
the women's
decathlon right understands that there
are differences
bruce didn't win anything though i mean
it didn't happen i don't know how that
works
and i don't want to be banned but also
on that note
um think about this california might
have a race between
uh a former vineyard owner who is
releasing
serial felons and locked down the state
and caused
more mass migration out from the state
uh than any governor before to the point
that they lost a congressional seat and
by the way also supports transgenders in
in people's sports is running against um
a former male olympian who killed a
woman and is now a woman
hmm if you were to put that up on on snl
or even back on mad tv as a sketch show
people like come on now there's got to
be
rooted in some sort of reality how do
you attack
how do you attack caitlyn like i really
don't understand from what angle you
come from
i tell you what i wouldn't be a huge fan
of voting for either of them but the
fact is caitlyn jenner is more
reasonable on trans policy than gavin
newsom isn't that crazy
wouldn't it be hilarious if republicans
voted her in
be like yeah what are you talking about
we don't hate trans people we just think
we just like the ones that make sense
the trump argument against against uh oh
yeah well was it glad it just came out
against
caitlyn jenner it's just so hard for
them to trip over themselves like come
on you gave
when when caitlyn still had a penis
woman of the year yeah
how's that patriarchy wasn't even fully
woman every year was still a man
i hate the gavin newsom's wineries make
fantastic wines do they really oh
they're fantastic
oh how dare you say that there's one guy
involved with that project that is the
savior of that he he spent a ton of time
with us talking incredibly nice guy
otherwise i would hate
cade and plum jack i disagree
[Applause]
hey caitlyn jenner did you see uh uh
elliott page's interview with oprah
winfrey
you mean that great big fat girl
[Laughter]
name that movie reference comment below
come on people if you
generation z doesn't know that movie
reference that's that's sad that's right
up there okay
so now i'm moving on to narcissistic
personality disorder
billy eilish hey you got it right did a
photo shoot
for uh british vogue hey must have
stolen those from elliott page's lawn
sale
nope one one
woman's trash is another one's treasure
gently used
[ __ ] gently never used sorry
that's just because bill o'reilly didn't
get to them first folks
elliot um
all right slow news terrible something
just happened with the pentagon they're
stopping the wall we'll go to cnn in a
second but look right now in case you
wondered about cnn's demographic
mesothelioma is still a thing
not only do you have to be so old to
have lived in a home where there was
asbestos that caused methothelioma
but you also have to in 2021 have not
yet seen the commercials regarding
mesothelioma
are they advertising to it's like those
advertisements i see for eggs
like well everyone knows about eggs
why are you spending money on this and
if you don't don't we kind of want you
out of the gene pool yeah maybe
you would think so no no okay so billy
eilish gave an interview for british
vogue
um and uh before i get into anything
else it should be noted that uh her
middle name is pirate
by the way i almost said really i almost
said he because i'm so messed up with
the pronouns
she's got so many middle names there do
you see that yeah i
was just one of many pirate is one of
them
so um while we're on the subject of how
awful men are
and how they're all the abusers she said
this about men billy island she said i
really think the bottom line is
men are very weak well imagine if those
roles were reversed i just think the
bottom line is women are really weak
now she doesn't say men are really weak
i don't know maybe just emotionally or
men are weak and she says men are weak
men
are weaker than women and she goes on to
say it's just so easy for them to lose
it you expect the dude not to grab you
if you're wearing that dress seriously
you're that weak come on go masturbate
okay good
let me just point out really quickly
before we move on to some other points
in this article which i wouldn't care
about if not for the fact that
it's i have to yeah
without men none of this interview would
be possible so the interview was given
to
uh british vogue uh obviously print
magazine printing press invented by
a man googleberg i don't think joe
hanzon a man invented the camera of
course for the photo shoot
arthur baldwin turner man invented and
created vogue magazine
i'm sure men were using the term loosely
the internet which is where this was
largely circulated was invented of
course
by a man during my service in the united
states uh congress
i took the initiative in creating the
internet
okay so i did it it was tim berners-lee
but you know that was back before
new media so al gore could just lie
completely
and something else to note her brother
phineas produced
all of her music and wrote most of it
really
so men are so weak you needed a man that
gets started
and you needed a man to make this now
look i think we need each other that's
the issue no one here is saying that we
don't need i think women are the best of
us
in a lot of ways in being compassionate
being nurturing obviously uh
making a house a home being great
mothers i think some professional
environments women are great
organizationally compared to men i think
in environments where you need people
who can do multiple tasks at once
women are far more efficient than men
and i think conversely
that men are far more effective at
carrying out one
high-intensity task like being in the
military or cia
but chuck one up on the board for you
ladies
well and one of the points that she made
i want to make this because women
misunderstand this they think it's just
like we just don't have self-control
when she says come on are you serious
you're just going to lose it like that
go and you know what she said right
we are hard wired for this you have
no idea what it's like and i mean that
if any woman out there is pissed off at
me right now
you're wrong you have no idea what it's
like to be
a 16 year old male trying not to think
about sex
i don't care what you're wearing just
hard enough as it is
but you add on top of it the kind of
things that people kind of dresses or
the kind of outfits
and to be clear whatever it is if any of
you guys are inappropriate of course
and appropriately they should be buried
beneath the tracks absolutely
you cannot i'll get to some other quotes
you cannot change that man's perception
of you
right that man's perception of you will
be primarily sexual now like
say i want to come home to her after a
long day at work
kick my feet up she seems like wife
material no it's more
ew it's a chemical reaction inside of us
and that does not give us any excuse to
be
idiots right and men or to be criminals
right and men need to do a better job of
helping other men
deal with that kind of stuff but you
have to understand it is not just
because men are weak
that's not weakness there are tons of
men who just i'm confused did you say
only 16 year olds
not just 16 year olds i'm just saying at
that particular moment in time it's
pretty difficult
yeah it's pretty difficult to think
about anything else come on everyone out
there
guys comment below tell me what was
okay look and i know we have a lot and
i'm a christian but this is just real
talk
what was your boner hide method in high
school did you go with the up tuck
how did we go this far or did you wait
for did you do the binder hide
right but books books work books work
but the problem is it depends on the
kind of book
well i think now we had to use soft
cover binders well the tablet now
at that point it's just at that point
it's just a dick imprint like the face
and the frighteners over the bed
so i'm just saying i went with the up
tuck the point but if you go with an
upturn make sure your shirt is long
enough and you don't stretch because
you're going to see no you're going to
see the model reaction
right now by the way phineas girlfriend
her her brother
girlfriend looks almost exactly like
billy eilish it's kind of creepy look at
this i don't know which one to shoot oh
wait really which one
is the clone it's got to be the one at
the bottom right why would you shoot any
of them
i wouldn't shoot both of them joking
okay
my main problem though with this
interview is um
what is this going on going on hold on a
second let's
son who was already benefiting from
educational proposals
oh this is about free preschool over how
was going to be able to afford
getting him in a quality preschool um
because the
the prices of these preschool programs
are ridiculous they are
um and i do feel strongly that each
child deserves
to have education but others objected to
fightings far they showed white people
we paid for actual walking my husband
saved for our children to go to college
now the money that he has saved they're
going to increase taxes
republican voter donna elliott likes the
traditional infrastructure parts of the
president's plan
creates jobs to upgrade our
transportation infrastructure
and stuff but says the administration's
approach goes too far
to include other priorities when you
take the word infrastructure you stretch
the definition of it now i'm going whoa
she is correct that infrastructure was
roads tunnels
highways trains buses it is that kind of
skepticism that will test spiderman
you mean textbook definition yes yeah
i thought when we said we were spending
money on roads that it would go to
improving roads and i didn't think that
it would go to uh
paying for transition surgery in the
military this kind of misinterpretation
of the meanings of words like
roads let and don't you love this show
they show the black family yeah the
preschool and the
white family so basically that can be
encapsulated this way it's like
we need we need stuff and then insert
commentary systemic racism
i don't want to pay for them blacks
that's how they try and make exactly
what that's the front end of that they
labeled her one percent did you see did
you hear it yeah yeah one percent
so people are watching a one percent you
know decry helping others and
how do they even know that oh my god
what if she's just walking she didn't
have a home
we have no idea this is news guys
democracy does not die in darkness it is
dying in broad daylight it is dying
in broad daylight 42 attempted suicide
rate those democracies
uh my main problem with this interview
with billy eilish by the way is that
everything let me let me be really clear
about this so when people my problem to
have talked about q anon in the past
where people think that everything is a
cabal of satanists and child sacrifice
satanism is actually far more common
than people realize and that most
satanists if you look at levee and
satanism they just don't actually
believe in god they reject the archetype
of god and what does that mean they
reject the tenets of the faith meaning
you should uh espouse the needs of
others first you should love your
enemies right that you should be held
accountable to god and that you
shouldn't simply look inward so
levaid and satanists actually just say
the opposite
they say that you should make yourself
the god of your own universe that's what
actual satanism is it's not blood
sacrifice it's simply saying hey there
is no god therefore i'm god
and i think this interview is strikingly
reminiscent of levaine satanism that's
right i said
satanism
[Music]
so let me read you a quote directly from
the church of satan since the sa
satanists understand that all gods are
fiction instead of bending the knee and
worship to or seeking friendship or
unity
with such mythical entities he places
himself at the center of his own
subjective universe as his own highest
value let's compare this with the billy
eilish quote uh quotes from the article
by the way
a role model for kids of course i missed
the days when charles barkley was a role
model and the worst he did was punch out
a fan
he's a good dad fan dessert was that
patrick ewing i think both of them did
probably um billy eilish said if you're
about body positivity
why would you wear a corset talking
about her thing why wouldn't you show
your actual body she raises her eyebrows
my thing is i can do whatever
i want confidence is her only gospel she
says yet that intent has been spun into
a lot of weird miscommunications he
clears it up
it's all about what makes you feel good
if you want to get surgery
go get surgery if you want to wear a
dress that somebody thinks you look too
big wearing
[ __ ] it if you feel good you look good
you
look good no no
do you know how i know that's do you
know how i know that's true because
you're not wearing a corset and push-up
bra
when you're at home binge-watching game
of thrones
you're in your sweatpants you're putting
that on to look good for someone else
sorry
that's why you wet that's why women wear
rouge to simulate the flushing
during a sexual encounter these are
these are biological facts these are
things that make people attractive to
the opposite sex that's why of course it
exists
small waist right we know this gentleman
who likes a small rib cage
we do probably watching the show man who
is oh jesus he is so
i love you we'll call him we'll call him
jay
he one time he was like this girl who is
stunning beautiful really really pretty
and he said you know i just i just can't
get past like she
she doesn't have a small rib cage i like
the ratio
of the small rib cage he's just he's
just
then she went on to say suddenly you're
a hypocrite if you want to show your
skin and you're easy and you're a [ __ ]
and you're a [ __ ]
if i am then i'm proud well wonderful me
and all the girls and hoes and [ __ ] it
you know
let's turn it around and be empowered in
that showing your body and showing your
skin
or not should not take any respect away
from you
okay here's the thing it does though
it does yeah shouldn't take any respect
doesn't matter guess what
if a young boy sees it and here's the
thing you can still be plenty attractive
i will tell you this
as a young let's just use as an example
young we were all sort of young
christians here yeah right
and so we would see attractive girls for
example a church
youth trooper at school you would see an
attractive girl and then you would see
an attractive girl dressed like a
prostitute now they're both the same
level of attractive
however you think of one primarily and
only sexually
and you think of another one as one you
respect and one you'd be interested
in courting that's a fact you can say
you wish it
didn't cause men to lose respect for you
it does
reality says otherwise and by the way
you know who is just absolutely lapping
this up
every producer in hollywood that wants
you to sell your soul to them for 10
minutes
tell every woman that it does it's
empowering to be naked and let every
stranger
on the planet see you having sex that's
empowering
right here's something let me read a
couple more quotes here i love these
pictures and i love doing this shoot do
whatever
do what you want do whatever you want
whenever you want
[ __ ] everything else um i don't know how
about responsibilities
how about love empathy compassion moral
virtue
responsibility discipline not [ __ ]
everything that's not adida von t's
branded corset push-up bra
there are other things in life that i
think you'll find are more important at
some point
but again this is the thing people will
say okay boomer even though millennials
like no hold on a second there used to
be a time we realized that when people
got older
they were somewhat wiser yes and other
things matter other than you know
your tits on the cover of vogue taken
from the yard sale from elliott page
and this is something else too that
really bothers me with this is
it doesn't really bother me honestly but
this is just really not a good message
to be sending to young women and they
don't understand that it's going to make
them inevitably very unhappy
it's an insane thing young women were
expected to know and do everything
and be everyone's mom when we're like
15. really
what what are you talking about what are
you talking about your brother
created the studio in which you recorded
all of your and he wrote the songs
and you just said yeah put my voice on
there
now the reason you probably are more
markets because you're a woman and
because you're more attractive and you
probably talented but your brother's
talented as well this idea too this is
something that i hear a lot from
feminists
and look this if if if you take nothing
else today
okay women i know we have a significant
amount of women watching yeah we
actually have more and more women
watching and we love you
in the comments because a lot of women
are saying i can't find a lot of our
life advice i can't find men
well look the reason for that is because
at some point women
as a whole are going to have to start
standing up for what actually matters to
them
you can't let the women in the media
dominate this message with putting trans
in sports
and dressing like strippers and saying
that men should respect them and what
look at some point you're going to have
to say you know what there needs to be a
civil war within women
meaning you know some people are going
to lose some weaves they're going to be
some some tops are going to fly off
upload it well look it's
but i want to i want to say oh you know
you have to be a mom at age 15. and this
comes from this myth you see from
feminists where they say we're expected
to take care of everything first off
that's not true
second it's we never had a choice you
hear this a lot now feminism is about a
choice i agree with that but we never
had a choice a lot of women will tell
you third wave feminists back then you
had to be a stay-at-home mom
no that's not true that's not true you
were encouraged
to be a mom and you were taught how to
be a good mom and a good wife just like
men were taught how to be a good husband
because these were important roles
in society however women back then there
were still plenty of women who were
working in sciences women who were
nurses women who were teachers there
weren't many women who were ceos
now some of that is nature some of that
is nurture because women typically
wanted to have children you notice this
when most women have children and they
start families
they don't often want to go back into
the workplace
because they find it more fulfilling
they find their life more satisfying
they find it more filled with purpose
but this is something they say
we never had a choice right you're
expected to be a mom no let me give
let me give you some perspective here
you're a young girl particularly any
young girl after let's say the 1950s
every girl watching right now i want you
to be honest this is a question
comment below okay it's the best thing
you can do and then i want boys
to comment below young girls out there
when your parents sat you down you
learned okay you were growing up you're
maybe going to junior high
you know maybe you're going into high
school the point is maybe you're
approaching that 15 16 year old mark
that billy eilish was talking about did
your parents say hey by the way
you have to be a stay-at-home mom you
have no choice or did your parents say
hey
look when you grow up you can be
anything you want to be
you can be a career woman you can if
you're playing i don't know some sport
volleyball you can you know
assuming that no men come into the sport
at this point you can play sports when
you grow up
you can be a ceo you can be a scientist
you can be a doctor you can also you can
also it's okay
to be a mom it's okay to be a
stay-at-home mom if you want to be a mom
that's something you can do too
as long as you have that choice is that
close to the conversation you had with
your parents or did your parents say
hey you don't have a choice you have to
be a mom okay
the world's out there don't do anything
other than being a mom now contrast that
with boys
let me ask you this anyone here any guy
here darren
i'm sorry dad i say darren sometimes
because i have to say for people who are
dad
pops gerald quarterback garrett anyone
when your parents had a talk with you
and i remember you having a talk with me
when you told me what a man should be
dad when he told me what a man would
have to do when he grew up any of you
were any of you provided with the choice
of
hey son now that you're getting older
you're going to have to learn how to
provide for yourself
you're going to have to learn how to
take responsibility oh and by the way
you can also just be a stay-at-home dad
that's a choice was anyone
ever even offered that on the table no
it seemed odd
it never came out like go to work i'm
totally fine
i'm totally fine but as soon as we were
old enough as soon as young boys are old
enough
to understand that they want to have a
life and family
we are made very aware acutely aware
that you're going to have to provide and
protect for the rest of your life that's
your responsibility
we don't get that choice i would argue
that women
have more choices and certainly choices
with less
pressure and you know what we want that
for you i want that from i want women to
have that choice right we wear that
proudly it's not something that we
disdain it just you're just showing like
there is a difference when you're
growing up on the expectations
and i know that there are plenty of
women out there who have to be they get
forced into roles of being mom
or being parents because the family unit
is breaking apart there i said it it's
the family unit that's the issue
going back to this over and over and
over you don't want to be a mom at 15
let's make sure that dads are staying at
home men let's make sure we have the
civil war with us and say look if you
want to be a jerk if you want to be a
sexual abuser if you want to be a
harasser
not cool we're going to kick your ass
we're going to make sure that you're not
doing that and by the way
don't call it mean whenever kids are
roughhousing in the barbecue and that
commercial from gillette
right we need that to understand there
are lines we can't cross
right and when you pull those things
away men cross every line
i just want look i just want women out
there to understand look you had a
conversation when you were young
young boys had a very different
conversation and it involved far
less choice and far more pressure and
they've always had choices my
grandmother your
great-grandmother born in 1900 college
degree
drove a car smoked full-time job in
outside sales yeah calling on men
in outside in saudi arabia that would
have covered her up to her head poured
honey on her and left the red army and
seater alive i mean that's something
just for the car
heretic yeah no communication no
refrigeration none of the things that we
in 1900 dirt floor and didn't our
grandmother play college basketball
no no she played high school basketball
no my yeah my mom was a
was a center when a 510 girl could be a
center yeah
today squashed by what was the handball
guy's name
uh yeah that's elliott australia yeah
elliott page uh but
in case you were wondering how none and
just again comment below young boys
sorry not whether when you were a young
boy and men
maybe you're a young boy right now we
have a lot of young people watching too
and women what kind of conversation did
your parents have
and if they didn't have that
conversation shame on your parents you
guys should all be having that
conversation with your children
um and i don't have a problem with it i
do think that young men should be taught
to be protectors and providers
and to make sure that we take care of
the women
for whom we are responsible in our lives
and i want that conversation to take
place with women and i want them to have
choice
but i want them to appreciate it and not
browbeat men every chance they get
because women
i'm telling you just like the black
lives matter backlash and just
like people now are seeing race more and
more and you're seeing more racism
you are going to see more misogyny and
more sexism
if you keep vilifying it's just not
going to be a good thing
for you uh but in case you were
wondering this doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense this interview with
billy eilish it almost seems like word
salad
you have to take into context that in
the interview she uh said i keep going
he because of elliot page
the pronouns they uh said that she
admires the multi-dimensionality
of meghan the stallion uh and
i think billy ellis was referring to
this megan
the stallion looking for a beat oh boy
if he ate my ass he's a bottom
of feeder ate my ass on the bottom
there's an episode of river monsters
i guess that's a literal somewhere deep
in the basin
where megan d stallion roams we find
ourselves a
oh cop i don't i just is that clever
i don't eat my ass you're about i don't
know which by the way is insulting your
own hygienically
hilarious yes that's true
oh no william eilish is going in my uh
playlist that's for sure no that was
megan's time i know it was i know it's
the
uh the whole lot all right hold on
what's multi-dimensionality i'm not is
she
big enough to exist well there's a lot
of megan v stallion
a friend to animals
yeah but that friend of the fish
she's a marine biologist can we just not
make up words to make people sound cool
like multi-dimensional
are you saying like there's multiple
domains i know what i think she means to
say that she's multifaceted she's
talented
or of course that may be talented it
could be it could be
a physical space thing i don't know it
could be about the circumference or
diameter i have no idea
i'm not look i am not above admitting
when i don't understand the science
of crustacean bottom feeders catfish
carp
i don't know what filter feeders do when
attached to megan the stallion's ass and
i don't know what makes it
multi-dimensional but i do know
that i'm close-minded enough to not like
it and i recognize about that about
myself
and i'm not going to work on it okay
everyone who is not a member yet
you can join up at light with credit.com
club we are about to go exclusive we
have some life advice
we haven't done that in a while people
are asking for it to come back and
youtube thank you not really dave landau
comes back tomorrow
you can piss off